pour les non-initiés william vance est
un auteur de bande dessinée pour les
initiés il est le père de personnages
mythiques tels que bob morane bruno
brazil 13
ramiro et bien d'autres des héros qui
ont un air de famille mais des
personnalités bien différentes et mc
innis en une vie plus facile et zac des
gens il y en a qui on attribue le
problème avec le passé il y avait eu des
clients qui sont des solitaires et ceux
qui ont déjà l'aï fait mais bon qui
qui se battent à travers l'histoire avec
plus de facilité car je vais gérer
quatre différents tonnages et paul marie
la venue de william vance est un
événement qui a réuni 300 souscripteur
d'un album original sorti dans quatre
villes d'europe
lausanne bruges bruxelles et le mans
c'est la librairie bulle qui est à
l'origine de cette parution
on a avec un éditeur flamand monter un
projet à savoir édité un livre à tous
petits tirages qui contiendrait du
matériel inédit qui ne serait jamais
sorti en album pour un bédéphiles un
inédit dédicacée par l'auteur est un
véritable trésor ce qui n'avait pas
souscrit pourront se consoler avec
l'exposition de quarante cinq planches
dessins proposés au palais des congrès
jusqu'au 31 décembre
[Musique]